Um, the point that we keep
getting away from them,
I haven't had an opportunity to,
um,
and Stephanie knows this as well as I do.
If you're gaining say
four pounds a year of fat,
or let's say between 20 and 40,
you've put on 40 extra pounds.
So now you're obese or a nice
lean, healthy young guy in
20, like many of us were.
And by the time you're 40,
you've got 40 pounds of excess fat.
That's the equivalent of putting in
about the 10 calories that she had to
storing about 10 calories a day into
your fat tissue that you don't burn them
metabolize. So you eat,
say 2,700 calories a day,
half carbs, you know, 35% fat,
15% protein and 10 calories that they get
trapped in your fat tissue less than a
bytes worth of food,
less than a sips worth of beer.
So the question or actually trying to
ask is our answer, and this is again,
just my approach as a curious journalists
too with a science background is how
do we explain those 10 calories?
Because when we talk about those
obese woman with starving children,
all those obese women were doing was
storing 10 or 20 calories a day depending
on how quickly they became obese and
those populations that tends to happen
quickly in their 20s. Um, so we're
asking this question, how do we,
if you've got a situation where we have
to end up with 10 calories stuck in the
fat cells every day, that's
20, 30, 40 billion fat cells.
So it's divided up very small.
And is the brain somehow regulating that?
Or again, is there a dysregulation
in the body involving,
pick your hormones, pick your
enzymes when the one, um,
that somehow traps fat in the fat cells
or prevents the fat from being used for
fuel when it's released from the fat cells
until if you think about it that way,
like you let yourself go to seed today,
Joe Rogan decides I'm done.
I'm going to do nothing but drink beer.
And you might start drinking five beers
a day and over the course of 10 years
you get 20 pounds and it's all here. That
20 pounds over the course of 10 years,
it's the only about 20 calories.
You might've added 800 calories of beer
to your diet and stored 20 calories as
fat. How does that happen?
And why does it go here
and not elsewhere in his step and said,
this is insulin dependent
fat tissue. Um, so those are,
that's when we're talking about this,
like this question,
could somebody get fat during a famine
or can they stay fat during a famine?
All they have to do is hold
on to 10 calories a day extra.
If they're only eating 1,210
gets stuck in their fat cells,
1,190 is excoriated are expended.
It's not that hard to imagine.
And there's nothing in the laws of that
says it to what could be dysregulated
about their fat cells, even during a
relative fam and not a complete famine,
but a relative family that might be,
and again,
an animal experiments of which
there are probably hundreds by now,
different animal models.
You can disassociate obesity from hype,
from eating too much in the animal.
Can I pause you for a second? Yeah,
yeah. So essentially you're saying
that even if someone is taking in, uh,
uh, a good amount of calories at the,
uh, the, uh, smart amount of calories,
2000 calories a day,
if you're taking in these
calories in the form of sugar,
your body is going to take a
certain percentage of them,
even if you're getting enough
food and stored as fat.
Whereas if you were taking in just protein
and vegetables and things along those
lines of your body would not
do that well.
So this is the gets to them mechanism
question and the evidence question.
So what you're saying that,
right,
so you're saying that if two
people are on the same diet,
one of us on 2000 calories of chicken
and fish and vegetables and the other one
is on 2000 calories of milkshakes and
no sugary drinks and pasta and bullshit,
that that person is going
to gain a certain amount of
calories and just put them
to fat.
Right? Regardless that's,
yeah, that's the hype.
Vivity this being a science at
hypothesis can be tested. Yes. Stephan,
thanks. It's been tested 80 times,
Steph, at times. I think it's,
they've done a bad job of testing it and
we will both tend to reject the studies
that we don't like and then we defined
on light by whether or not they got the
answer we think is great.
Your perspective that
this is not the case,
your perspective is that like as you
were saying in this study with a closely
monitored these people's diets and
they added additional fat in a,
an additional carbohydrates that they
both gained the same additional amounts.
Yeah, that's right. I mean if
cares is a shot, this is correct.
You have to see different levels
of fat gain. I mean, Gary's,
the short term study that they
did was how short term was it?
Two and three weeks. That's very
short. Yeah. It is very short term,
but still Gary says that insulin is the
thing that gets fat in fat cells and
that, I mean you would see
some kind of difference.
It insulin made any difference. You
should've seen some kind of effect, right?
Some kind of difference in
fat gain. I actually, um,
I don't want to start taking out charts,
but this gets intense when dynamics
that was worked out so over, uh,
um, I promised I wasn't
going to say boy, Oh boy,
oh boy on the show. But it's my
thanks to my Brooklyn born mother.
It's my program then.
Um,
and they the same is true.
A lot of these overfeeding
experiments do the same thing.
So when they talk about over feeding,
they, they, they literally overfeed.
So they kind of do a reasonable way
of figuring out which reading is,
Stephen said they measured,
uh,
they calculated how much energy they
needed to stay in energy and balance.
And again,
right there,
that's a problem because one of the
hypotheses says that the energy balance is
dependent on the macronutrient
content of the food.
So you're going to get a different,
different level depending on what
the macronutrient content is and then
different level of, of what, what's
necessary for energy balance.
So the classic example is a study
that's my not for profit funded,
that's been very controversial where they
got their subjects.
This is David Ludwig and Cara ambling and
their their colleagues at that Harvard
and Boston Children's hospital. And they
did this study in Framingham and they,
they basically got a subjects to lose a
10 or 12% of their body weight and then
they randomize them to
three different diets,
have three different
macronutrient composition.
And they basically calculated their
energy expenditure on the three different
diets,
which is kind of exactly what we're
talking about because if you want to be an
energy balance, who know, you feed
people exactly what they're expanding.
And in that study,
which was published a year ago,
and they saw different levels of
energy expenditure depending on the
carbohydrate content of the Diet.
So the higher level of carbohydrates,
this is trying to keep them in energy
balance. The, the higher the carbohydrate,
the lower the energy expenditure,
the lower the carbohydrate,
the higher the energy expenditure.
So again,
it's just whether or not they
did this study, right? Who knows.
Science is a compilation of a lot of
studies and we're trying to, you know,
address exactly this point,
but
merely building that into the experiment.
We know what their energy
expenditure shouldn't be.
And then the point is when
you increase in part, again,
part of the trick of doing science is to
say, look, we have competing hypotheses,
uh,
multiple hypotheses and it's
vitally important that you
always keep the multiple
hypotheses in mind when
you're interpreting the study.
So one hypothesis says it's how much
they eat and another hypothesis says it's
what they eat and that what they eat is,
is moderated primarily through insulin.
And when you do these experiments,
like the experiment that, that uh,
Steve, Steven is talking
about, Stephan, um, no,
I'm completely confused.
Uh, if you overfeed them,
you start out with a 50% carb diet.
Now you overfeed them.
If there's a threshold effect on insulin,
which turns out there is,
and you're just moving them.
And when you look at insulin dynamics,
when insulin is below a very low point,
the fat cells will mobilize
fat and the lean tissue,
we'll burn it for own. Above that
point, you get pretty much flat.
So if you start people who are eating
1500 calories from carbs and you add them,
pump them up to 2,500 calories from carbs
are still in the plateau side of the
incident. You wouldn't necessarily
expect to see any difference.
The only way you expect
to see a difference,
and that's why it helps
to really interrogate both
hypotheses so that you know
when you're doing the experiment,
whether or not you're actually
testing something, you one hypothesis,
you want to set up the experiments
that all hypothesis predicts.
The two hypotheses predict
something entirely different.
This experiment with arguably the two
hypotheses predict the same thing.
You'll get fat gain because
insulin is elevated regardless,
and when insulin is elevated,
you're going to get fat gain.
The question comes back to it. This,
again, always vital to keep this in mind.
We want to what could possibly cause at
10 or 20 calorie excess that causes fat
storage. I have a friend who was
four to 400 pounds when he was 18.
It was a tall kid, about six
foot five. Um, he was, uh,
say 200 pounds over weight,
200 pounds overweight is roughly a hundred
excess calories over 18 years stored
in your fat cells. That's, you know,
even if you assume that you have to
consume 300 calories to have 100 excess
stored in your fat
cells, that's, you know,
one to Coca Cola is a day that he was
drinking or one half a quarterpounder a
day that he was eating that is lean
friends weren't in. The question would be,
why can't he just stop doing that again,
Stephanie would say,
cause there's brain won't let him and
I would say because his insulin is
elevated, it doesn't matter
whether he stops it or not,
he's got into addressing
underlying mechanisms. Okay. Okay.
Um, all right. So now again,
it's easy to tell stories.
It's not easy to tell stories that are
supported by scientific evidence. Now,
um,
I want to bring people's attention
to reference number 11 on my site.
There have been 29 studies now that
have measured differences in energy
expenditure, metabolic or Kevin
Hall study met analysis. Correct.
There have been 29 studies to date
that I've measured calorie expenditure,
metabolic rate on diets differing
in carbohydrate and fat content.
And when you put all
those studies together,
when you are at least the first 28
together and you look at what the overall
literature says,
it makes almost no difference to
metabolic rate whether people are eating
carbohydrate or fat.
And in fact this very small difference
that it does make actually favors high
carbohydrate diets so you get a slightly
higher metabolic rate when the Diet is
predominantly carbohydrate.
Now this study that Gary cited is the
one study out of these 29 that has
reported a larger effect in any others
of carbohydrate restriction on energy
expenditure.
So this study reported in effect
bigger than any of these other 28 and
difference. We went on this.
You're not done, please. Thank you.
Um, and, and interestingly,
if you actually look at the data and
these data have been Rhea analyzed by a
researcher named Kevin Hall.
And if you look at the data,
you find that some of the participants,
some of the data that represents some
of these participants are literally
physically impossible. They break
the first law of thermodynamics.
This is the conservation of energy.
Gary knows about this.
He has a physics background and
they literally don't add up.
And when you start subtracting the earth,
the clearly erroneous data
from the pool of subjects,
this big effect size starts to shrink
and shrink and shrink and shrink until
after you've gotten rid of all of it.
This study does no longer,
no longer reports a higher
energy expenditure on a
very low carbohydrate diet.
And it's consistent with the
previous 28 studies that were done.
So that's my perspective on that.
But I want to go back to this. No,
no dare you taught for a long time and
I'm going to talk for as long as I want
now.
Um,
I wanna I want to talk about human
energy metabolism and this idea of the 10
extra calories a day. Gary, I,
I really continue to get the feeling that
you do not understand human energetics.
Um,
because that's not how it works.
Now I'm just saying 10 calories
stored in the fat tissue. 10 calories,
10 calories and say anything about how
much you have to eat. I'm not done. Okay.
No, but you're in top thing. We
carry. Got To stop doing that dude.
Gary back thing like you think I'm an
idiot. All right. Are you done now?
Are you done? Can we be clear that
we're talking about you done now?
Can I just finish this? No, you can't
do until I am done without Gary.
You have time to respond.
You can respond,
write down notes on what
you want to respond to and
after he's done you can tell
them, but we're going to get
out [inaudible] course on this.
The thing that's not the point.
No. Is this line. Thank you. Okay.
Now what you see,
there's basically two things you need
to pay attention to here in terms of
energetics.
One is the imbalance between
intake and expenditure,
and that is very small,
so it only takes a little bit of extra
calories to cause somebody to start
gaining fat. However, as they
gain fat, their bodies get bigger.
They're gaining fat and lean mass.
People with obesity have more fat and
more lean mass and their calorie needs go
up and up and up and up.
The larger their bodies get.
And so even though the imbalance between
energy and taking expenditure is small,
their calorie needs end up being quite
a bit higher. Can I pause for a second?
Yeah, so you're saying that
someone just gaining calories,
eating additional calories,
their body gains lean mass as well.
That's because fat. How is the brain
regulate that? I didn't say it. Regulated.
Medical doctor, Garrick Guy.
Hold on. So fascinating.
Like how does the brain muscle muscle,
they're gaining muscle tissue.
Some of its muscles.
Some of it's okay.
It's just because they're carrying
around this extra weight and so the extra
calories and then on top of that carrying
around the extra weight forces their
body to grow larger. Presumably, I'm, I'm
actually not sure what the mechanism is,
but it doesn't have anything to
do with the brain. Coincidence.
I don't know what causes it. That's
what I'm saying, Gary. Okay. Now, um,
so,
but the point is by the
time the person has obesity,
they are consuming 20 to 35% more calories
than they were when they were lean.
So that's not just a one or two cokes
a day that is allowing them to remain
obese. They are consuming
20 to 35% more calories.
That is what the most
accurate studies are saying.
And so it's not just 10 extra calories
or maybe just one or two cokes.
We're talking about a substantial amount
of extra calories and it's not as a
generalization because we
don't know what I mean,
what's the ratio of how
much fat people get out,
how much weight people are
gaining. Everybody gains a
different amount of weight.
Like you're saying,
they're eating 20 to 30% more cowards.
Like who is like how many people, how much
are they gaining? Like people get fat,
they get 20 pounds overweight.
People get fat,
they get a hundred pounds overweight.
They made a very, that's right. Yeah,
and that's why I give a range because
what you see is that people who are
overweight, so they're in the overweight
range, you just have some extra fat.
They eat about 10% extra calories.
People who have a little bit of
obesity eat about 20% extra calories.
People who have,
who are very have very,
very great obesity eat more like
35% is it packs with the amount,
I'm sorry,
is it possible what he was saying that
if you do consume 10 extra calories over
long periods of time that will
accumulate extra calories.
You're accumulating hours,
like 10 diamonds going into it is,
so how much do you have to deposit?
Correct.
It is correct that if every day you eat
10 calories more than what you need,
then yes. Or get bodies or your
body stores. Yeah. We'll say that.
If your body is storing 10% 10 10 extra
calories over top of what you need,
but the thing is that as you get bigger,
what you need goes up and up and up.
Because you're carrying around more.
Correct. And so it's 10% in text or cow,
sorry,
not percent.
It's 10 extra calories on
top of the elevated amount
that you're already eating.
So you end up with these big differences
in calories take. So that's how,
that's how it really works.